happy Monday everybody
so everyone's condemned the footage of
the beating death of Tyree Nichols by
five black cops including even Barack
Obama and Donald Trump
finally Unity it's the most they've been
in agreement since deciding Stephen
Colbert isn't funny hey
but I'm glad we're finally talking about
black on black crime
of course though it involves cops you
know the line if it bleeds it leads it
only works if it leads to the cops and
maybe great white sharks it helps out
they're white
but these five officers aren't can they
still be racist it's hard to say because
they and the victims are black and so it
presents a quandary to the left who
hates cops but doesn't want to put black
criminals in jail
so what do you do next well you a race
race but just this once
when will the brutality finally lead to
some police reform from the ground up
because
clearly it doesn't matter if it's a
white policeman or a black policeman it
is a problem in the police and the
policing itself so now race doesn't
matter
well what if it didn't matter before and
you just thought it did because that's
all the damn media focused on and now
perhaps all this incident did was show
you that by eliminating race as a
variable and you see the real causes
that's got to be good right well hold on
because you still need your dose of
racism and now it's about who trained
them translation white people that has
to be it I mean hell even Mike Tyson was
trained by a white guy
so there's your end race baiters
someone else must have taught them how
to behave this way systemic racism for
the win van Jones writes on CNN CNN's
website that blacks aren't immune to
anti-black messages he blames
self-hatred which is bound to happen if
you end up writing for CNN
I'm sorry van
but he claims blacks are socialized into
departments that view neighborhoods as
War zones a place where rule books don't
apply so blacks are more apt to single
out young black men for abuse but the
problem here is the phrase single out
were there more choices in that
neighborhood than black
probably not it's like bragging that you
bought something for a buck at the
dollar store
so if all these choices for the black
cop is just black then it's not race
just like it might have been not about
race for a lot of those other cops
but while this latest crime tells you
it's not about race van still says hold
on quote it's hard to imagine five cops
of any color beating a white person to
death under similar circumstances
well you would have to imagine it
because no one would cover it the fact
is we have just as many incidents of
unarmed white guys getting killed they
just don't hype them up and release them
like a movie over and over and over
again so if whites trained blacks to
hate other blacks so they'll beat on
other blacks as opposed to other whites
well they can get blacks to call Larry
Elder and Uncle Tom I'd say yes
but the fact is minority officers are
just as likely to shoot a minority and
some data suggest more likely and why
well they're in that neighborhood more
frequently more often and on purpose
it's their job to be there it's where
more arrests are made and where more
encounters violent or otherwise take
place
but let's not let white racism off the
hook either it's what brings us
everything from Kamala Harris to cringe
Jean-Pierre white racism refuses to
judge blacks the way we judge whites
it's what G.W Bush called the soft
bigotry of low expectations but I don't
think there's anything soft about it
it's straight up racism hiding behind a
mask of cowardice it lowers standards
everywhere it elevates people into
undeserved positions overlooking
training experience better candidates
you make life less safe out of fairness
from crime fighting units to the
military standards are lower to fill
positions well except for the NBA
but if you made it more white you'd be
lowering the quality of play
we predicted that as police became more
maligned and many retire others will
just leave for more lucrative private
gigs so who's going to take that job
will anyone that applies they're less
selective than when I was single
so what have that scorpion group a newly
formed police group that killed Mr
Nichols were recruited on just Merit
alone would you have seen the same
outcome who knows maybe perhaps of the
five cops there would have been
different skill sets and temperaments
and experience you know diversity where
it counts and not just for show
let's hear it welcome
tonight's guess
I dream about him reading me my Miranda
rights former NYPD inspector Paul Morrow
[Applause]
he's ruffled more feathers than my
feather ruffling machine
the author and Fox News contributor
Douglas Murray I love that
this young man proves you don't need a
sense of humor to be a comedian HOSA
Across America Jimmy Bayla
Jimmy
and she loves giving back to her
community all the stuff that she stole
buses contributor captain
so Paul I find this uh there's so many
elements to this story that if you we've
already had we already assume it's a
horrible horrible horrible thing that
happened to that man
but then you then you realize that the
one variable that we've all been pushing
in the media is not part of it and then
what happens it becomes about training
and why training so that they could talk
about systemic racism yeah except the
fact that the chief of the entire
department is herself black right yeah
and you know I think what happened here
that we have to remember is that think
about how rare An Occurrence like this
has to be because look at all the focus
we have on it right and remember that
the majority of police throughout the
country are getting deployed with body
cams right so if this were to happen
again someplace else with white people
to your point you'd see it yeah we'd
know about it because it's on body cam
the fact that these guys were cammed up
and still felt free to do what they did
tells me that there was a real lack of
oversight they were out there sort of on
their own an echo chamber of their own
they only see each other they have the
same days off et cetera and a thing
develops where they start to sort of
pair away from the rest of the police
department it becomes its own thing and
the culture that developed was very bad
if you look afterwards they left the
body cams on which is real trouble for
them because it's all coming into the
criminal case they're fist bumping it's
very celebratory right this is a
cultural thing it's not a race thing
interesting and it makes me think I
don't like to traffic and gossip I'm
above that but but
see you always start with the preamble
did they know this guy
you know these conspiracy theories
always float around after something like
this and then it's like that's the
Memphis there's a lot of stuff in
Memphis about this it's like the Pelosi
thing right you know because the stuff
doesn't come out and then all of a
sudden there's all these theories and
everybody buys them because it's sexy
it's fun et cetera I'm going with
Occam's razor here which is just a
simple explanation is the right
explanation which is that these guys
were a unit that and think about the
name of the unit I mean scorpion
poisoned from the well right yeah what
does the Scorpion do it's things and
kills you yes right I mean there's units
like this in New York NYPD they call it
what it is anti-crime yeah you call it a
scorpion unit you're kind of sending a
message yes yes
so you see what likely developed here
and you know as I said I have a piece up
on foxnews.com that dropped over the
weekend that essentially said the Net's
going to get wider and it's coming out
now there were seven cops suspended the
day of got five indicted but says more
charges coming so we're going to be
living with this story for a while
Douglas uh you uh come from a place
called England and they do have police
there I'm told yes they're called
they're called Bobbies they were called
Bobby's about 200 years ago yes yes now
did they were they on Horseback at the
time they're always on Horseback
obviously we don't have cars yet in
England of course you buy cars now
though we do now yeah yeah yeah recently
important just trying to get the
audience up to speed
when you're looking at this and you're
from I know it's hard as a as a Brit to
talk about these things but what do you
see in this well by the way Britain
picks up this stuff from America like
that yeah no seconds flat uh British
commentators have been saying this is
all about white Supremacy and white
supremacy and the policing maybe they do
the same shtick as they get from here I
mean the problem is this is what happens
when you have a very simplistic
narrative and it's false it breaks down
right it just breaks down if you're one
narrative in recent years has been white
supremacy and the police and then you
have five black cops killing a black guy
you've got to say
still white supremacy yes and uh you
know some people will go along with that
but not many I reckon I mean you know
there were 30 people shot in Chicago
last weekend mainly black people shot by
other black people was that also white
supremacy I suppose we'll just have to
pretend it was look at what the
president said the other day you know
the meant to be the great uniter of this
country he says once again this is you
know that I'm so tired of seeing you
know so exhausted he said so exhausted
black people are seeing seeing people
killed on camera but as you say I mean
you you could if you wanted pick this
stuff out you can find Tony Timber being
killed online right if you want to watch
white people being beaten up by cops you
can find it it's just we don't go on
about it yeah and I just hope that this
is one more nail in the coffin for this
idea that the main thing in America on
everything is white supremacy it's not
true it's always been a smear of this
country it's gone on for years it got
gas fueled in recent years and this is
really time to stop the world is more
complicated than this simplistic level
narrative excellent yeah
I want I want Douglas's wish to be true
but I know that's going to hurt your
white supremacist newsletter that you
put out in the in that little apartment
above your garage
it's an email stick with me no no you
chose you think that they're monitoring
your email so you just do the newsletter
just do an old school snail mail yes uh
he's kidding by the way I think we're
like where do I sign up you know what I
mean no it's crazy uh but the whole
narrative this anti-cop narrative is how
we got here we've been trashing cops you
know since 2020 and it drove most
qualified candidates away from the gig
you know and that's the bigger issue
here is we demonize the noble profession
when I was in first grade when you were
in first grade if you were to ask every
kid in the class what they wanted to be
when they grew up half the boys would
have said cop half the boys would have
said fireman nowadays half the boys
would have said girl and the other half
and the other half would have said drag
queen I mean that's where we'd be but
this is there's nothing wrong nothing
wrong with it nothing wrong with it all
that's my other newsletter yeah with me
but we drove the good people away from
the job and that's really the bigger
problem is when you lower recruitment
standards okay you get less qualified
people certain things you just don't
want too cheap you know what I mean we
all like that ad for 50 laser eye
surgery to the cross-eyed doctor walks
into the room and that's where we are
here you just have to support the cops
across the board I would have been a cop
if it weren't for this thing called the
background check but the point is we're
fighting the wrong battles that's all
sorry well cat you're uh you're very Pro
police
many of them know have come to know you
over the years uh
I was so worried we were talking about
this topic I was like what if we don't
have a diverse panel to discuss this
issue
but then I was like oh thankfully you
invited the British guy
I ticked that box uh yeah look I think
that it's
I don't think it's good to you just say
you support all cops across the board
because there's big cops right there's
people like this uh which is why I think
it's got to be accountability for the
police and uh you just look at it in
terms of accountability of anybody who's
in government it's the same exact thing
I mean this video there was nothing
controversial about it I mean I watched
it I cried I was sick I was just I was
physically sick I was disgusted and I
think anybody who watched it had the
exact same reaction and I think that
like you mentioned I read your piece
Paul I thought it was great talking
about some of these special units how do
they recruit for these units because
there have been problems with these kind
of units in Detroit in the past years
ago and in other instances what makes
you want to join a unit like this is it
the lack of oversight that some
sometimes these units have we need
oversight
um so that things like this don't happen
all right fair enough hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else